ronin how did that happen with call of
duty i mean you know how does it even
feel knowing you're in a video game oh
man so you know i uh at first i was in
the history channel when i was filming
there so
uh
the third best jewish athlete of all
time behind sandy koufax and adam
sosnick there it is yeah wow
yeah so that was my first time being on
the set like literally that day was my
first rookie year yeah
that's day one
that was the second season so we did
three seasons really popular uh it got
really so it was uh broadcast in like 12
different uh countries this is what show
night knife or death beating the hell
out of ice with knives ropes don't stand
a chance yeah so you're a big dude man
the goldberg must be six six how big is
this guy uh he was 260 there
yeah height wise i mean that guy's not
so he's like six four okay he was a
defensive end in the nfl before he was
arrested that guy don't play yeah but
he's still he's so intense you know i
want to bring you to this day so i'm
here right now he's intense
you're literally the most intense person
i've ever met in my life and you're
calling him intense so i had my nose and
i was seeing it dude it was like 115
degrees in the hangar because they had
these fire barrels but it's in the
middle of the summer in atlanta right so
i had these flower so i'm sitting there
and it gets hotter during the day people
don't know the lights that are on so
it's hotter and hotter and hotter bill
comes in with his shirt off his cowboy
boots
you know and he was like it's so
hot in there
and he goes i need a cooling tent and
this and that and i'm like i don't even
know what a cooling tent is so then he's
a typical hollywood star
love him then he looks at me and he was
reading his notes and he looks at me he
goes
are you meditating because i was
sitting there
like this and i said i'm slowing down my
heart rate not anymore bill where i'm
slowing down my heart rate because then
it it cools down my body so i won't you
know uh sweat
right
so here's bill trying to manage he's so
funny though you know that was one of my
first days you tried to you got bill
goldberg to try to meditate he tries man
he's pretty he's pretty cool dude right
so uh he has a spiritual side of him
what what you see he is high energy
but getting back call of duty so we are
doing close quarters training in uh san
francisco right and uh infinity war they
follow us you know on social media on
youtube so i post where i am and i post
like what i'm doing right training and i
was training close quarters battle
and uh
if andy ward uh emails us and say hey
can you fly out to la you know so here
we are we're toting our guns our
equipment can you pull that up type in
call of duty 2 lamb
and then uh we go out there
it was my wife and i and we're standing
out there and we met the president right
so first we met the teams and they're
broken man they're so professional
they're broken up so creative and then
the president comes out and he was a fan
and he he said hey man big big fan thank
you for everything you do
and he goes he talked to us for a good
three minutes and he said how can i get
you on the game
you know
excuse me
he goes how can i get you in the game my
wife is standing there and she goes well
if you want ronan
he has to come in zronit and he goes ah
okay what else and we run our own gear
yeah we design
and then she's like well you know you
want that then you know
he wears his own he goes okay done deal
is that your gear that's her
basically what they did was they plucked
me out he just threw me in the game
literally you know special force for
them all that right and i did the motion
capture
uh so you see there and motion capture
in the uh studios
with them um
you know we uh we recently did motion
capture all the gun scenes and
everything
uh with them so
it's it's been really uh
amazing journey and you know what what i
take from this
is that uh
man you know a bunch of kids are playing
my character now
that's gonna be wow a bunch of kids but
you know what
you know bruce lee when he was an actor
right
he used his platform to spread about
equality
right about martial arts educating
people and i do that the same you know
i'm not bruce lee obviously but i
use my platform to to spread the word
about
compassion love you know
um
leadership right so i use that i'm
giving the tools to all these youth
right they're such a multiple age right
now and they're playing my character so
why not give them a word where does the
character or your alter ego
ronin where does that come from because
that's
what is that the basis of that
so you know i i lived the life of
bushido i live the life of the way the
warrior right so bushido in japanese is
broken down bull means to intercept the
spirit to go to war
she is the one who chooses to walk the
path the one who's strong enough to walk
the path the way where and do is to take
your whole life experience
and to give back for the sake of
humanity
bushido
right so i walked the path of bushido so
let me explain what ronin means so
back in the frugal stating periods of
japan were staying pierce japan you had
samurai who served the daimyos right so
if you were fired you become ronin
masterless so it was very shameful this
honorable to be a ronan back in war
staying pierced japan but there were
ronans that were
you know famous like miyamoto musashi
the 47 ronins you know there were
stories of these ronins they were
amazing so where did ronin come from you
know i was uh
after i got out of the army i was
heavily addicted to painkillers
you know and patrick would tell you man
like that's a normal thing in in our
world you have a similar problem did you
not no
okay
but patrick would tell you like in this
special operations world we thought he
had that dude we mask our pain man
it's such a um
intense world you know that world
special operation swirl
you come back from a rotation a combat
rotation you can't even talk to anybody
about what happens you're driving
defensively on the road and you don't
even know why you're doing because your
brain is switching to that level
so i was really messed up right and i
got out
and i was sitting in the dark room one
day
defeated defeated my wife was working on
the dimmer i was defeated caught up in
pain killers wanted to quit
then the voice told me get up
so i got up i had this blanket and
walked around the dark house and somehow
ended up in my library and i opened up
this bookcase and i have books
from since i was
gosh i started reading since i was 11. i
had books all around the world too right
and somehow i just reached in i grabbed
the book didn't even look it was the
book of five rings by miyamoto masashi a
ronan
that was born in the late 1500s and died
in 1645 after writing a book of five
rings now i'm holding in my hand he
wrote it in the buddhist cave after
meditating for three years finding his
peace here i am holding this book in my
hands and the pastor said all your love
all your emotion everything exists
everything exists look nowhere else but
within
so it's a legendary book by the way it's
like a uh you know art of war five rings
um
you know
40 laws of power i think talks about
five rings yeah it's it's a 33
strategies award book also spends a lot
of time talking about that fascinating
stuff so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you